und dann gab es in Deutschland endlich
mal wieder einen richtig zünftigen
Medienskandal alle Mann anschnallen die
Bild-Zeitung fährt politische Kampagnen
und der Boss Matthias Döpfner hat
schlimme Ansichten nein hör doch auf mal
ganz ehrlich wann waren Sie zuletzt so
wenig überrascht
meine sicher unter döpfners von der Zeit
geliebten Kurznachrichten waren schon
ein paar echte Körper dabei ne Sätze wie
die Ossis sind entweder Kommunisten oder
Faschisten dazwischen tun sie es nicht
eklig
SMS und dann auch noch gespickt mit
Rechtschreibfehlern obendrein ist auch
noch dieses Foto von seinem Dienstwagen
aufgetaucht haben Sie das schon gesehen
junge
ach das war eine Fälschung von uns ja
guck mal
drecks Lügenpresse viele langweilige
alte döpfnersätze klingen jedenfalls im
Nachhinein plötzlich lustig für die
Erfüllung der Vision unseres Gründers
Axel springe das eines Tages das
geteilte getrennte Land wieder vereint
ist in Frieden und Freiheit und wenn es
soweit ist werde ich es wieder Teilen
mit Arsch blöden sinnlosen Beleidigungen
ne ansonsten hat er die BILD-Redaktion
im Bundestagswahlkampf aufgefordert mit
ihrer Berichterstattung vor allem die
FDP zu stärken was jetzt natürlich nicht
heißt dass die das dann auch eins zu
eins zu umsetzen und ich sag mal ohne
Ende geile FDP Schleim Schlagzeilen
raushauen das wäre ja wahnsinn ich meine
so eine unabhängige Redaktion ich
schließlich kein bring-dienst wo man
sich bestimmte Meinung quasi bestellen
kann
oder in den Worten des Meisters selbst
wir Medien
sind Chronisten Zeitzeugen der Realität
nicht Missionare eines bestimmten
Weltbildes
eben und ich bin mir sicher dass auch
bei Springer noch Leute arbeiten die das
wirklich so sehen der Redaktion ist das
wahrscheinlich super peinlich was der
Chef da rausgehauen hat ist kann man
sich nicht ausdenken muss man zum Glück
auch gar nicht
jetzt neu im App Store gbt die Pöbel KI
für verlagsbusse die zu faul sind selber
zu pöbeln geistiger Dünnschiss im
Buchstaben gegossen inklusive
Rechtschreibfehler perfekt
aber auch völlig absurde Sätze auf die
man nicht mal besoffen käme Christian
Lindner hat auch manchmal gute Ideen
es sei denn du bist aussieht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also gut
hat sich ja nicht entschuldigt so
richtig entschuldigt aber er hat sich
inzwischen erklärt das Handy sei sein
Blitzableiter leider hat der Blitz
offenbar das Handy verfehlt und es
direkt in seine rüber eingeschlagen ne
klar man kann trefflich streiten ob es
ethisch ist halt private Nachrichten zu
veröffentlichen andererseits Bild und
Ethik
viele der Nachrichten gingen an den
gefeuerten Chefredakteur Julian Reichelt
ist das jetzt seine Rache und welche
Rolle spielt Benjamin von Stuckrad-Barre
dessen Springer Roman diese Woche
erschienen ist der war ja auch mal ganz
dick mit döpfern befreundet bis die
Bromance dann erkaltete keine einzige
dieser brennenden Fragen beantwortet nun
Dietmar Wischmeyer
der Literaturtipp mit Dietmar Wischmeyer
gute Nachrichten
Deutschlands letzte große Verleger
Persönlichkeit matthias töpfner hat
endlich sein gedicht-zyklus vorgelegt
bestehend aus handybotschaften der Titel
ach du scheiße was habe ich denn da
letzte Nacht wieder geschrieben
Kurznachrichten für die sich sogar Til
Schweiger schämen würde jetzt auch als
Hörbuch gelesen von Rufus Beck und eines
feingeistes wie Matthias töpfner absolut
würdig free West [__] the Internate
gesprochen mit hartem ch wie ein Fuchs
und Dachs und schon assoziieren wir bei
der Lektüre intensiv den bestialischen
Gestank des heimischen Raubzugs ein
lyrischer Geniestreich der gleichsam
spielerische Umgang mit Rechtschreibung
und das zur Schau stellen eines offenen
Rassismus zeugt von Souveränität
bei den großen Fragen der Zeit weiß ich
der Autor aber auch augenzwinkernd in
der eigener Blödheit und Arroganz zu
verstecken meine Mutter hat es schon
immer gesagt die Ossis werden nie
Demokraten vielleicht sollte man aus der
ehemaligen DDR eine agrar- und
produktionszone mit einheitslohn machen
nicht geändert die Ossis deutlicher kann
man die indigene Bevölkerung der neuen
Bundesländer nicht abstrafen was ist
dagegen noch die Forderung nach einem
einheitslohn wo der Osten schon heute
die Heimat des niedrig lohnt ist aber
geschenkt das kann ein Milliardär wie
das noch nicht wissen dass er sich auf
international am Parkett zu Hause weiß
davon zeugt seine politische
Urteilskraft mein Vorschlag
Friedensnobelpreis für Trump und IBAMA
wieder wegnehmen was für eine mutige
Idee doch wer ist dieser die Barmer wir
werden es von hier fahren konkret wir
dürfen nur beim Thema Innenpolitik
unsere letzte Hoffnung ist die FDP
können wir für die nicht mehr tun
it's a patrioticuty letzter Hoffnung FDP
aussichtsloser hat kein Schriftsteller
unser aller Schicksal jeden Worte
gefasst für sowas bei tinder schreibt
wird gnadenlos nach links geswt
so viel für heute liebe Leseratten und
in der nächsten Folge besprechen wir
Julian Reichel Herr mit den jungen
Volontärinnen die fiktive Geschichte
eines fiktiven Chefredakteurs und
Benjamin von Stuckrad-Barre wo warst du
döpfi die noch fiktivere Lebensbeichte
eines mega fiktiven fiktiv Erzählers
über seine fiktive Männerfreundschaft
guten Abend
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen